so as if people really know the results
I David have been the axon returning
office of the above election do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate at the said
election is as follows Neil Carmichael
the Conservative Party candidate twenty
nine thousand three hundred and seven
David drew later uncooperative party
twenty nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety four Boonville goggly in UK
Independence Party 1039 Sarah London
Green Party 1423 Maximilian Wilkinson
2053 there were ninety seven votes
rejected twenty five for voting for more
than one candidate - for marking by
which the voter could be identified and
seventy as being marked for uncertainty
so there were 97 rejected boat boats the
number turnout was 77,000 as I announced
before and in the light of the above
folks I do hereby declare that David
rhew is duly elected to serve in
Parliament for this rally
[Applause]
I'm going to try and front my way
through this can I just start by
thanking David and all the team of
people who made our evening special
I'm sorry as always it is this rad thing
that we seem to manage to delay things
and Julie but it wouldn't be any other
way if it wasn't what we did in traffic
I'd also like to thank the other
candidates we got to know one another
rather well we've had nine Hustons I
think that's partly responsible for the
throat but it is important that we put
ourselves before the good residence of
Stroeve and they have had the
opportunity to see what we stand for and
what we would argue in terms of this is
the seventh time I've done this I should
retire more often it's just important
that we understand that this is an
important election I did argue all the
way through I thought this was an
unnecessary election and one that I
never thought that I would come back and
be a victor but it is important that the
people of Stroud like the people in this
country have had their chance and
they're saying it has been rather a
surprising result but as I felt from the
outset this was the wrong time to call a
general election and maybe the Prime
Minister will be thinking about her
position more than anything because I
think that we have to move on from the
tragedies of Manchester and London and
we need to pull together as a community
in hearing Stroud but also nationally
there are so many people I could thank
I'm going to in particular obviously
John my Asia and Tim who acquired the
role of
the organizer the rizal most successful
in organizing me which is a major
achievement but there are lots of people
have fought with me you know Hilary's
not here tonight because she couldn't
stand the thought of me losing again now
getting to stand the thought of me
winning again but there are lots of you
here have been through this journey this
is 25 years now I've not ever stood for
anything for the short-term gain I
believe that you have to do politics
properly and for a long term so I'm
delighted to go back to Westminster
there are a few things I left unfinished
but more than anything I'm delighted for
those who supported me and those who
have stuck with me so let's celebrate
tonight and let's look forward because
there is a new dawn as John would say
and it's a new dawn which is somewhat
more red in color than sighs intended so
thank you for listening let's
you